- What if I don't win?
I just want her to love them so much.
- My nuggets are gonna be fantastic.
MSG's gonna be the reason why I win.
- I am really gonna try to make this plate
look pretty for Inga.
- [Alexis] Fingers crossed.
- Spice it up.
(exciting music)
- Hello, it's Inga
and today, I am challenging three cooks
to spice up a mystery dish
which is chicken McNuggets.
I love chicken nuggets.
I think they're perfect as is.
I'm really curious to know
how people would jazz it up.
They have 45 minutes to
come up with something
and then at the very end,
I'll pick my favorite.
Let's see who can spice it up the best.
- Hi, I'm Alexis and today,
I'm gonna make my version
of chicken nuggets.
My boyfriend said that
these chicken nuggets
were like the best he's ever had.
I don't know what Inga
wants or is looking for
but these are truly
the best I've ever had.
So for my chicken nuggets,
I'm gonna start by grinding my own meat.
I'm using chicken breasts
and I'm just gonna blot
them dry with paper towels.
That's just to get any
like extra moisture off
and the reason that I'm
grinding these myself
is because when you do that,
you have more control over
what's in it obviously.
There's not like other
spices or preservatives,
no extra water content in there
and also, that means I
can control the texture
and the size more.
Just gonna cut these into
like half inch cubes.
So the reason that I'm putting the chicken
on a parchment paper lined baking sheet
is because I'm gonna actually
throw it in the freezer
for like 20 minutes.
So you don't need it like
totally ice cube frozen.
You just want it to be frozen enough
that it's gonna blend and get chunky.
Back with my frozen chicken
and the food processor blade
which I also had in the
freezer and that's just again
to help it get to the right consistency.
So you can see that
this chicken, it's like,
yeah, it comes off the
parchment paper super easily.
It's like hard but not like rock hard.
Pop it in the food processor bowl.
When dealing with raw chicken,
it is very important to wash your hands.
Okay, so chicken in the bowl
and now I'm gonna add some heavy cream
and I've got rosemary,
thyme, oregano, salt.
Looks like a lot of salt
but it's chicken breast.
You need salt and pepper.
All right.
I don't want big chunks but I
do want some uneven texture.
It does look like cat food
right now but just bear with me.
All right, I'm ready to
shape my chicken nuggets.
Okay, my chicken mixture.
I've got another parchment
paper lined baking sheet.
So just take like a heaping tablespoon
and put it on the baking sheet.
You can make them in any shape
and that's really the joy of it.
Okay, I've got all my
chicken nugget shapes.
I think they look really cute.
I'm gonna pop these in the freezer
and then I'm gonna make the sauce.
What are chicken nuggets without sauce?
There's so many good sauce options
but today, I'm gonna make a barbecue mayo.
Super simple, it's mayo,
barbecue sauce, smoked paprika.
The smoked paprika's gonna
give it a little kick
and it's just gonna add like
a little depth of flavor.
- If I was a spice, I'd be cardamom.
My boyfriend says I use
cardamom in everything
and that is true but I
think it's such a nice like,
again, depth of flavor.
Okay, I think that this is
like sufficiently stirred.
It looks so good.
I would love to put my finger
in it but this is for Inga
so I'm just gonna put it in the fridge.
I'm gonna do a classic dredging situation
for my chicken nuggets.
I've got flour here.
I've got salt and pepper.
It's again just gonna
add a little more flavor.
I feel like with something
like chicken breasts,
you really wanna add that
extra salt and extra flavor.
Some really beautiful eggs
and then I've got panko.
First, into the flour and
whenever you're dredging,
you just wanna make sure that you get
like excess flour off excess egg
so that it's not like a
big, weird flour chunk
that gets fried.
I think you could totally bake them.
You're making a chicken nugget.
It's not like the time to really be like
so health-conscious, right?
I've heated my oil to 350 degrees
and I'm gonna fry my
nuggets for a few minutes
until they're golden brown
and hit 165 in the middle.
That's the temperature you
want chicken to be cooked at
and these are just like slowly frying.
They look great.
That's like the perfect nugget.
Have you ever seen something more perfect?
I feel so proud of these chicken nuggets
and I feel like they are the best.
Even if I don't win, I feel
like she's gonna love them.
I'm sorry to everyone else.
This is perfect.
I love it.
Okay, I think at this
point, it's just up to Inga
so fingers crossed.
- Hi, I'm Kanchan.
So I'm gonna turn Indian
inspired chicken kabobs
into nuggets.
I grew up eating these chicken kabobs.
They were my grandmother's recipe
passed down through the ages.
It's been a long time
since I had some McNuggets
but I remember them pretty fondly.
So we're roughly chopping some chicken
and putting it into a food processor.
So to our roughly chopped chicken,
we are going to add
some red onion, garlic,
ginger, fresh cilantro and mint
then we're going in with garam masala.
Garam masala is a traditional
Indian spice blend.
It has a bunch of beautiful spices
like cardamom and cloves and
cinnamon, cumin, coriander.
It adds warmth, peppery
notes, kind of earthiness.
It's just a match made
in heaven for kabobs
and then for heat because
it's all about spicing it up,
we are going to add some cayenne pepper
and we're just gonna finish this
with a generous sprinkling
of salt and pepper.
Okay, so now we're just
going to pulse this
until we have a kind
of kabob nugget mixture
if there is such a thing.
If there isn't such a thing,
there will be after today.
Now it's time to shape our nuggets.
We wanna go in with wet hands
so it prevents sticking
as we shape the nuggets.
So we're going for that classic
kind of flat-ish, roundish no shape shape.
You also wanna have it not too thick
so that it fries up quickly.
Now we're just gonna freeze our nuggets
for one to two hours.
The secret to an
award-winning chicken nugget
is an award-winning sauce.
So we are going to make a chutney inspired
kind of ranch dressing.
To the food processor, I'm
adding some Greek yogurt,
more fresh cilantro to really
bring out those flavors
in the kabob nuggets, fresh
mint leaves, jalapeno peppers,
garlic, lime juice, sugar
to balance things out
and salt and pepper
and we're just gonna
blend this until smooth
adding water if necessary.
I grew up eating this green chutney
on sandwiches with tomatoes.
I grew up dipping these
kabobs in this green chutney
so this is a really nice way
to kind of pay homage to my childhood.
Cool.
We're gonna make our dry
mix and our wet batter
so we can fry these kabob nuggets.
To my dry mixture, I'm going
to add all-purpose flour,
potato starch.
Potato starch will add crispiness
like it does to the traditional
Japanese fried chicken karaage.
So that's my little
trick for crispy nuggets.
And then we're just gonna add
onion powder, garlic powder,
sumac for kind of tangy,
lemony, earthy notes
and a little bit more
heat with cayenne pepper
and to this, I'm just gonna
add a little bit more salt.
Really hoping that potato
starch works its crispy magic.
So for our wet mix, we
are going to add two eggs,
water and some more potato starch.
We're gonna mix this really well
and now we're ready to
bread and fry our nuggets.
So now that we have our frozen nuggets,
we're just going to take our nuggets,
dip them in our dry mixture,
pop them into the wet batter.
I'm gonna use one hand
for wet, one hand for dry.
That way, I don't make a gooey mess.
And we end in the dry and fry.
If I were a spice, I would
be the child of sumac
and like red chili powder or cayenne.
I just love the heat from the chili
and the sort of lemony,
fruity, earthy tang from sumac.
These are all breaded
and ready for frying.
We're just gonna pop these
nuggets into our hot oil.
All right, we got some
crispy brown action.
We are ready to take 'em out.
Ooh, nice and golden brown.
I really wonder what my
grandmother would think
if she knew I turned her
kabobs into McNuggets.
I feel like she'd be pretty pleased.
We're gonna start by
plating our dipping sauce,
our chutney ranch dressing.
That's just what I'm calling it
and of course, we're gonna
top it with some spices.
We're spicing things up.
So we have a little dusting
of cumin, some coriander
and some more of that spicy cayenne pepper
and we're gonna try to
plate these beautifully
and tantalize Inga's taste buds visually.
There we have it, garam
masala chicken McNuggets.
- What it do, everybody,
my name is Ross Pineda.
I am the chef and owner of FYEH Kitchen
and I will be making spicy nuggets.
What makes my spicy nuggets spicy?
Spices and a certain ingredient
that not a lot of people
are fond of or know about.
It's MSG.
Monosodium glutamate is
like a food additive.
It is a flavor enhancer
and a lot of people have
this negative connotation
that's like it's bad for you
but anything in excess is bad for you.
A little bit of love goes a long way.
Pretty much, we're gonna go ahead
and start with our ground chicken.
I'm using ground chicken thighs here.
It is the juicier part of the chicken.
You can use chicken breasts
but I feel like it gets weird
after you like fry it too much
and then it gets like dry and stuff.
Fantastic, all right, so
we're gonna use this spat.
Pat it down.
Give it some love.
We're gonna throw in some
salt, throw in some paprika,
some can jan, cayenne pepper.
We call it can jan in the kitchen.
This is white pepper.
This is gonna make it crazy.
Some black pepper, onion and garlic powder
and then I'm just gonna
mix this up real quick
before I add the flavor booster.
All right, cool, bam, MSG.
MSG's gonna be the reason why I win.
It's like a little kick.
Just wanna add some happiness
and joy to your life.
It is dredge time, guys.
Got some cornstarch here.
This is the best way to
make something crunchy
without just using regular AP flour.
I feel like people should
have this stuff in their crib.
Then I got some potato starch.
It gives a nice texture.
This is my regular AP flour.
Put it in there.
We're gonna add all the
spices in this dredge
because you wanna have all
the same flavors except MSG.
Throw some salt in there,
garlic powder, onion powder,
white pepper, black pepper, paprika.
Gonna whisk it all up.
If I was a spice, what would I be?
Salt.
If you ask all my best friends,
I'm the saltiest person you'll ever meet
because I sweat a lot and I'm
always upset at something.
We're gonna be dredging
our chicken two times.
Making a mess.
My chefs would be proud of me.
So now we're gonna form
some chicken nugget patties.
Dip my hands in water then
form some some nuggets.
So we're gonna set 'em on that tray.
Talk about life.
How your grandmother won
the lotto the other day
but she didn't give you any money.
Now that our nugget patty
things have been formed,
so we're gonna go ahead and
chill this for about 20 minutes.
Forgot my spicy apron.
Bam, so we've gotta work on our batter.
I've got eggs here, my golden
whisk 'cause we bougie.
Gonna throw in your buttermilk.
So all you wanna do is make
sure that your buttermilk
and your eggs are fully incorporated
because this will be the key to success.
We have these two trays of the dredge
and I'm stuttering right
now because I'm so nervous
'cause I want these to come out so well.
Take one.
On your first tray,
you're gonna dust it ever
so, so kindly and lightly.
You just wanna treat it with some love.
Quickly dip it in your egg
mixture with the buttermilk
because buttermilk and chicken go together
like lamb and tuna fish.
If anybody gets that reference,
I will love you forever.
We're gonna dip it in the
second one for an even coat
and we're gonna transfer
it over to our tray.
We're gonna repeat this as many much times
as you have pieces of
chicken and then we're done.
Now they're all floured and nice
and we're ready to set them in the fridge.
So now we're gonna build our sauce.
Now, I'm a big fan of mayonnaise
but I'm a bigger fan of Kewpie mayonnaise.
What is Kewpie mayonnaise?
Kewpie mayonnaise is mayonnaise
that is pretty much egg yolk
based and has MSG in it.
I've got some ketchup and pickle juice
'cause sweet, sour, salty, spice it up.
Got some white pepper.
White pepper is something
that a lot of people don't really use.
It is very pungent.
It's very pungent smelling.
This is the consistency you want.
It's drippy and it looks good.
This is done.
We're gonna do a double fry, guys.
We're double frying
because one, we would like
it to be extra crispy.
So we're gonna go ahead and fry these
and then remember, don't
drop it like it's hot.
You're gonna drop it like it's not hot
because you don't wanna burn yourself
and the reason why I'm moving them around
is because you don't want
'em to stick to each other
but yeah, these are
getting nice and crunchy.
They're floating so that means
a lot of things are cooking on inside,
they're getting nice and not raw anymore.
Nuggets are done with their initial fry.
I can only fit five in
this spot over here.
I'm gonna lay 'em over.
My oil's gonna come back up
to 350 for the final fry.
The second fry is the shorter fry.
So we did the first initial
fry about six to seven minutes.
It's gonna be about like
two and a half to three
depending on like I said
how big your nuggets are
or how hot your oil is
or how fast it goes down.
Yada, yada, yada.
Sometimes you're gonna get
these like nice little,
really dark deep brown
parts but that's fine.
That's all flavor.
The nuggets are looking fantabulous.
Anyway, so now we're gonna
lay it back on our paper towel
but we're gonna go ahead and try these.
We're gonna go ahead and plate.
I'm gonna go ahead and arrange our nuggets
like we're feeding the president.
So cheers to you, all my
nugget lovers out there.
Oh my God.
These are good.
That is our nuggets,
spicy nuggets 'cause we're spicing it up.
- We have these three beautiful
plates of nuggets here.
I guess I'm just going to start here.
For this one, I can already smell like,
even from here, I can smell the spice.
First bite, I'm just gonna
dunk it in the sauce.
This one has so much flavor.
Oh my goodness.
Oh, it's just super, super fragrant.
I'm also not used to seeing so
much color going on in here.
Crust great, flavor great.
Okay, moving on.
Ooh, okay, this one, beautiful crust.
Good crunch.
The sauce is like sweet and tangy.
Mm.
Tastes great with the sauce.
Tastes great without the sauce.
Okay, moving on to our last one.
But I'm gonna dip it in here.
Mm.
There's a bit of a kick
to it which I love.
Look at how juicy that is.
Dear Lord.
Overall, fantastic nugget.
I have come to a decision
so let's bring everyone back
and we will share who the winner is.
Thank you all for coming today.
They were all so great.
The first one I tried
had incredible flavor.
So many spices went into it.
The second one, beautiful panko crust,
amazing mouth feel and texture.
The third one, the heat of
it and just like so juicy
but this is my winner.
Tada.
I love it, are you surprised?
- I was like, wait, that
doesn't look familiar.
- Everybody, try it.
Amazing, right?
- This is the best chicken
nugget I've ever had.
This is incredible.
- I'd like to thank God
and my dad for teaching me how to cook
and my love for nuggets.
Thank you, guys.
- That's it for today.
Tell us in the comments what
we should spice up next.
Otherwise, we will see you next time.
(calm music)